are the few in the proud switching to
anything's allowed and will our military
be ready without getting a mani-pedi
that's good as part of a push for more
diversity and inclusion the u.s marine
corps has approved several uniform
changes because if there's one
cornerstone of the marines it's letting
people do their own thing
on that list marines can grow their hair
up to three inches instead of two and
edge it up to make for neater haircuts
they can now wear black or olive socks
in addition to brown yay but the
exciting part female marines can now
wear two-tone nail polish although it
must be in shades of pink or red that
quote complement skin tone oh that'll
make for a sexy salute
now of course plenty of people are
calling all these changes woke bs maybe
it is or maybe it's changing with the
times
speaking of changes in the armed forces
the army has dropped its plans to have a
six event physical fitness test that is
gender and age neutral apparently men
were passing the test at a much higher
rate than women
and older soldiers who now who will be
allowed to pass while meeting some
reduced standards
hmm it's as if biological males have a
mysterious advantage when it comes to
physical strength good good thing they
never compete against women
that was like a call back brian we do
that here
right i know you're good
i know it's early in the morning when
you do your show you don't do that sort
of thing you know i have i have a
morning show i don't even know i don't
in a couple hours yeah that's true you
know katie i'm gonna go to you first
first of all we should be we should
always salute the people who enlist yes
of course um is this like i mean does it
really matter this stuff i mean if it's
like if you know it's weird because like
usually these institutions shape the
people but now it's people
shaping
the institution that's correct analysis
so on the updated regulations are we
really that worried about them changing
from black socks to olive green socks i
mean it's not like there's much variety
with what they're changing but the
physical fitness is i think a problem
because
if you want to win a war people got to
be in shape and i'm not sure if this is
a result of them not being able to find
qualified recruits because if you look
at the the pool of people available who
are signing up the majority of them
can't pass the physical fitness test so
they've lowered the standard
that's a big problem but i think you
know enemies looking around the world
are going oh great the united states of
america is lowering basic fitness
standards i think we'll be okay if we
decide to go in against their military
it's okay if the rest if the rest of the
planet
is doing the same thing but i'm not sure
they will
here's the counterpoint tyrus is this
really a problem if basically the future
of war might come down to just pushing
buttons and drones i mean that's perfect
for any body composition even kill meads
okay first of all you've killed me alone
the man is is physically fitted you see
the size of the backpack he walks around
tremendous shoulders and you know he's
got to work that's a compliment almost
no that one
[Music]
your backpack game it's strong
here's the problem
the nfl the nba
you have to be a certain level of
athletic skill to do it right
the army and the marines are the same
way you are defending the country you
are in some cases being dropped off in
the middle of nowhere and there's a good
chance you don't want to have a french
manicure when you hit the ground that
glares off the lights or the enemies
things i'm just i'm just speculating
here and i don't think women in the
marines were really doing cartwheels and
jumping up and down going hey we can get
our nails done they're worried about
staying alive and
saving people so again this is more of
the same of that external group who try
to change things instead of saying hey
stop being so chubby get off your ass
you got to train and you might not get
in to be able to defend this country if
you're not in shape instead it's oh well
their stuff's too hard it hasn't been
too hard to make us the safest nation in
the world and have the number one
military on the planet actually i think
we're the top five because people
sacrificed and worked their ass off to
get in here to earn the right to wear
that uniform it's not just they people
just want things given to them now so oh
i can't do ten chin-ups but i should be
able to defend my country no you
shouldn't until you take the time and
energy and do those chin-ups
get get your ass in gear and then get
there you know kat uh even though you're
a half a veteran
uh do you think you would fail every
single test even with the lower
standards
i know i
i know i would yes
i would love to see you do one chin up i
bet she could i don't think so give us
give us a week she's wiring
that's
disgusting to hell with him enough of
this next week you're doing a chin up
we're going to improve and if she
doesn't chin up he has to apologize you
know when you look at her look at her
arm just look at her keep it up like
that look how long it is no just it's
really long
thinks that ritalin stunted my growth
and i'm like you put me on it
those are amazing it's not like a
promises are great you're a fleshy
praying mantis i never really noticed
this it looks like it's like a little
mosquito bite on like a string of
spaghetti right here
long muscles are great for boxing and
chin ups i bet you could do it i bet you
could do five
it would take you an hour
bet him let's do something yeah i've
never done it i can't do it okay no but
again i don't think military service is
for me which is why that's why i married
a veteran so i could be a half veteran
yeah but
again i don't think this describes
anyone with like the nail painting where
they're saying they want to get they're
trying to recruit more women i don't
think there's a single woman out there
that's like i want to be a marine but i
can't have a french manicure so i'm
going to be a dentist like i don't think
that describes anybody yeah yeah yeah
that's a good point you know a kill meat
the test uh for men of your age 63
requires a two mile run in about 23
minutes could you fail that test no i'm
great at long distance
i did
a couple of things yes
hr called you violated everything on
every page in the entire handbook put up
your arm let me judge you i mean oh my
goodness i cannot believe i think i'm
somehow an accomplice just by being on
the set we're gonna edit
all right are you it
for this try to follow me yeah if you
believe there's a difference in a man
and a woman then you cannot have a
problem with two versions of that test
because women can't compete physically
with men and if you believe that in the
a block in your b block to be consistent
there should be two separate tests
excuse me uh i like he actually gave me
a second katie i had one second i had
you thinking go ahead it was actually
it's actually a really good point and
then that but then that goes to the next
point it's like then what do you have
two separate armies
wow yeah
well i mean there are separate like
there are not
there are separate duties in separate
absolutely separate units obviously i
guess they should be in the highest
standard is what people should mean
maybe they should you know yeah cats
long arms
all the pots and pans right absolutely
some pans off they
you've been bragging about your long
arms this is the first time i've seen
that it's pretty amazing like it's not
working the same way for you no it's not
i'm just all right up next will robbers
seize the day if you're wearing too much
cartier hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else